when you turned 40 this past year we
always forget we're the same age so do
you do you feel different
at 40. I feel like I like life a lot
better the more I mature I like life but
like I think it's just better it's
easier you're wiser but like um also
like things hurt yeah it didn't hurt or
you can't bounce back as quickly oh
definitely not just the one thing that
happened after 40 was I like to incubate
a lot more I like spending time with
myself my family my priorities have
suddenly become really clear the I don't
sweat the little stuff
um but also your metabolism takes a big
hit yeah you're like oh I see that
sandwich for the next week yeah you know
or that pizza and I love food I live for
food me too you know but my job is not
yeah like doesn't like the fact that I
love food as much as I do so that
changes your relationship with your body
changes
um I used to work a lot I still do I
work a lot I love my job I feel very me
too I like working I love working I love
my job but you know you get tired yeah
you want to go home and like I'm really
looking forward to napping after the
show yeah and that would be nice and a
nap I mean by like sleep like
yeah I don't know why I said nap really
I mean usually I think because I don't
get a full night's rest and I need it
but like no I just mean a full night's
rest I'm very excited about it yeah to
be able to sleep eight eight hours oh
yeah if you get it it's well you have a
one-year-old you might not get this card
it's hard
um
[Music]
[Applause]